thank you very much for having me here
and i hope
people are not yet sleepy so
just to make sure we'll do another
exercise
can i have everyone raising your left
hands
and now both hands
and stay there for a second i promised
my mom
awesome
thank you guys
so thanks so much for having me here
it's amazing iceland reykjavik it's
beautiful
and
it's also quite awesome to be surrounded
by so many javascript enthusiasts
eager to learn and share their
experiences
for the next half an hour hopefully less
i'll be quick to not
keep you longer here i'll be talking to
you about a topic i'm very passionate
about
speech recognition
and most excitingly of all i'll show you
how you can empower web applications
with
voice triggered interactions
first off uh
let me just tell you a bit about myself
one second so i work
for a sports technology company called
huddle
which builds an analytics tools
for coach coaches and athletes at all
level to help them win
and
second
have a
technical difficulty here
just my s it always happens speaker
notes
going
odd so
going back
i want to tell you a short story so
i've been playing around with speech
recognition for about four years when i
was studying it for my master's degree
and i was quite intrigued by how hard
of a problem this is uh just imagine all
the various factors
like
accent pronunciation
articulation roughness mosality pitch
volume and speed that influences how
it performs
in practice
speech looks a lot like this
it's a continuous sound wave
whose amplitude varies based on the
sounds
involved the speech recognition process
typically goes through the following
steps first is place the sound wave
by silences into what are called
utterances
it's basically words or other
non-linguistic sounds
then each utterance is split split in
frames
and for each frame we have
something that's called a feature vector
which is basically a set of number
representing distinguishable properties
of that sound
and once we have all these things
we employ a classifier that takes a
series of models
to identify and do the matching process
based on those properties and figure out
what the speech is about
so
just a quick brief
overview have an acoustic model
that contains
acoustic properties for distinct units
of sound a phonetic dictionary which
maps the words to their respective
phonemes as they're called these units
of sounds that constitute words
and the language model that allows to
make the
search space easier based on already
recognized words to be able to
find the relevant ones based on
probability quicker
and
the speech if you wondered is actually
hello world
just in case you're wondering
in practice speech recognizers are
assessed based on two things
accuracy and speed
for accuracy
it's the word error rate
which looks at the ratio between the
insertions substitutions and deletions
over the total number of words in the
reference feeds and you can see quickly
in an example there what that means
and speed
is the real time factor
the decoding time over the speech time
so now just to make sure i don't lose
you can we do that exercise again so
everyone left hand quickly right hand
and wave a bit
awesome
perfect
so
let's see some use cases so probably a
lot of you are familiar and you might
already use personal assistant apps like
siri
and
in practice speech recognition engines
like the one that powers empower
siri out of two types
the ones that
are speaker independent
so basically regardless of the speaker
so all the things like pronunciation
accent they don't matter they're
supposed to recognize their speech and
speaker dependent which basically it
involves an extra training step
for a particular speaker
where they need to read some predefined
templates sentences
to fine-tune the recognition process and
increase the accuracy
and
just to continue on
with my story earlier
towards the end of my studies i had a
great opportunity to put in practice
what i learned about speech recognition
in the research team at mozilla
and
the project was to build a speech
recognition engine
for firefox os and for those of you who
are not familiar with firefox os that's
the mobile operating system that mozilla
built and they're
heavily developing it that's based on
web technologies
so being a research project the focus
was more on exploring what's even
possible in terms of speech recognition
on the web mainly using javascript
rather than having something solid solid
production ready
so during my time there i've built a
pure javascript speech recognizer that
performs the speech recognition process
on the client
without the need of any cloud-based
solution that where you just send the
speech and you get the results back
and i would show you a quick demo of
that
feel free to ignore all the details
there they're not really relevant for
the scope of this talk so the idea is
i'll show you an example for
recognizing digits
which is made possible given
for digits the models the language model
phonetic
dictionary and acoustic model are quite
small and can be easily loaded on the
client
so let's try out some numbers
three two one
here you go and as you can see in the
console it basically shows you the
result it also shows it on the page
and some performance i was talking about
real time factor here you can see 0.082
basically a real factor of 1 means the
decoding happens in real time it takes
the same time as it took for the speech
and for this example you also see
three different
solutions which
are one different than the other
that's basically
in the process of recognizing speech
it takes different probabilities and you
see some various scores there which
might not make much sense but it ranks
the possible outcomes and in this case
as i chose here the what's called end
best hypothesis i chose free so i got
the top three
awesome
going back
to the
this project that i built if you are
interested to know how it works
and
all these kind of details feel free to
find me after this talk or
ping me on twitter or the jscom for
slack
and
little did i know around the same time i
was researching this
and building
that speech recognizer at mozilla the
team for from google
were writing up a spec for what they
call the web speech apis
basically defining javascript apis that
would allow developers to
incorporate speech recognition
into their web pages
and about a year later in 2013
these were
supported experimentally in chrome
version 25
and
these were building up on top of a
feature that
chrome released from version 11. which
was to have
speech input with this attribute called
x webkit speech
for input fields to allow to
users to
use the voice
to input
data into forms
and now let's see how these apis look in
practice
you first need to instantiate the speech
recognition object and since the apis
are still experimental
they do
need the browser prefix for chrome
not for firefox though
some of the most
relevant configuration attributes
for speech recognition are the language
one
which allows you to set the language
that will be recognized and
chrome google supports 32 of them
including icelandic as i found out
an attribute that allows you to specify
if you are interested in
interim results so as the speech
goes on
you get
results that might differ
also the continuous if the speech should
be
listening continuously
and finally
the
max alternatives which is something
similar to what i showed you with the
end best hypothesis
and there are a few event handlers
provided for the speech recognition
interface and i would recommend you
check the full api at that link there
however the minimum needed to get you
started are the one result which gets
called whenever you have a speech
recognition result on no match
when no match was found for the current
speech
and
on error
when an error look work
in terms of controlling the recognizer
we have a pretty self-explanatory api
start and stop
and
before we wrap things up
i just want to
show you how the speech recognition
result format
looks like
so this is basically the
event that comes
into the on result
event handler
and it has a few
properties is final which says if that's
the final result that the recognizer has
a high
confidence about
the index in the result so if the speech
has multiple results
and then an array of speech recognition
results
which
contain again various properties but the
one you're interested in
is
the transcript
which tells you what it actually
recognized it also has one that says the
confidence which gives you a confidence
score
so this seems quite
straightforward
and
did anyone notice
anything
and i guess you probably already see as
a spoiler
on the slide
for the past few slides
i was actually not clicking anything
to switch between them
i was using
speech recognition
to talk about speech recognition
and let me just reset this so that you
see it happening
live
so
as i was saying
come on you can do it
as i was saying
i was using
speech recognition
to talk about speech recognition
and
how meta is that right it's quite cool
and you can see as a type
well
it it likes to make jokes as i talk as
well
so
the
grayed out
text
is
what i was mentioning earlier the
interim results
and now it detected the keyword and it
decided to go crazy on me
so
the grayed out text was the interim
results
and
start out again
perfect here you go
and when it becomes white that becomes a
final
result
exactly you know it best
so you might be wondering
can i use this now is or is it behind
those like crazy browser flags
and that no user will know how to turn
on
when they're using your
application
and
unfortunately
the support is not that great
it's only chrome and opera that's
supported out of the box
and firefox with the special web speech
recognition flag
and as far as i know microsoft is
working on adding support for that
and
that might be unfortunate but as we all
know with
web apis it takes a while until they
become the norm and all the browsers
implement them
and
on that note
i hope you will use this knowledge to
build very exciting apps
so thank you very much
you